lafleur
les exploits du démon blond ont été une
source d'inspiration pour une foule
d'artistes dont sus du groupe loco
locass
c'est quelqu'un effectivement qui a
transcendé son sport qui le charge et
d'inde une charge symbolique
dans lequel un peuple en type peut se
reconnaître
des chansons qui lui ont rendu hommage
il y en a plusieurs dans boules à mites
daniel boucher a chanté le dit l'acteur
de son enfance
[Musique]
guy lafleur est à l'origine de ma
passion pour le hockey comme un club de
hockey canadien
ok ça commençait le fameux soir du
septième match qu'on bosse temps dans 79
ok donc
g7 ils comptent culturel le numéro 10
aussi inspiré des artistes visuels comme
serge lemoine récemment exposé au musée
national des beaux-arts de québec il a
fait de cette génération
au sommet de sa popularité
guy lafleur s'est aussi fait artistes en
réalisant en 1979 un disque de disco
prodiguant des conseils de hockey une
fois que tu contrôles y était flic
ajoute un peu de l'arrondissement
aujourd'hui c'est pas tout à fait ce que
ferait un sportif évidemment mais c'est
normal c'est sort son univers culturel
celui qui a remporté cinq coupes stanley
aussi marqué notre imaginaire collectif
en jouant au petit écran comme ici dans
l'émission chez denis excusez moi
monsieur la flash si j'avais su dis-moi
dis-moi part dans la bataille elle
on l'a aussi vu dans différentes
publicités
bonjour
dois vous avouer une chose j'ai pas vu
passer adulé par tous cet amour du
public lui allé droit au coeur il ya
moins d'un an il était ému aux larmes
devant cette nouvelle sculpture de
l'artiste guillaume tardif inauguré à
québec
c'est le genre de personne qui inspire
plusieurs les plusieurs artistes mais
aussi plusieurs communautés à vouloir
c'est comme marqué dans l'espace qui
dans le temps le passage cette personne
ne
dit la fleur restera à jamais dans nos
mémoires d'ailleurs un film sur sa vie
pourrait voir le jour en 2023 je connais
personne
qui n'aime pas ou qui la foule à moi de
le voir décoller à l' aile droite puis
décochez pour moi ça c'est une image
l'immortel ici mais bien alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal